- [Voiceover] Which shape
matches all three clues?
So here we have three clues
and we want to see which shape down below
matches all three of these statements.
So let's start with the first clue.
The first clue says the
shape is a quadrilateral,
quad meaning four-sided.
So looking down here at our shapes,
let's see which ones
match that first clue.
Shape one has one, two, three, four sides.
So it is a quadrilateral.
Shape two has one, two, three, four sides.
So also a quadrilateral.
Shape three has one, two, three,
four, five, six sides.
So it is not a quadrilateral.
It's a six-sided shape or a hexagon.
So we can rule that one out.
It doesn't match clue one
so there's no way it can
match all three clues.
And finally shape four has one,
two, three, four sides again
so it is also a quadrilateral.
So after clue one, we still
have three possible answers.
This first shape, the second
shape, and the fourth shape
all match clue one,
they're all quadrilaterals.
Looking at clue two, it says
our shape has no right angles.
Right angles are also 90 degree angles.
Right angles are 90 degree angles
and they look something like this
and we often see them marked
with a square in the middle
because they are sort
of like square angles.
We can create a square from
the opening that they form,
that these angles form.
So this is a right angle.
Looking now down at our shapes,
we can see right away on shape
one has two right angles.
There's a square corner
and another square corner.
So this has right angles,
but the shape we're looking
for has no right angles
so we can rule this shape out.
Shape two does not have any right angles.
These are not squared off corners.
And same with shape four, no right angles.
So both of those still match
both clues one and two.
So we have two shapes left.
They're both quadrilaterals
and they have no right angles.
And finally our last clue,
the shape has four sides,
we knew that 'cause it
was a quadrilateral,
and those sides are of equal length.
That means each of the
sides is the same length.
Looking at this first one
that we have left, shape two,
it looks like these sides on the ends
are shorter than the
sides going up and down.
So it looks like they
are not equal length.
So we can rule this one out.
But let's be sure this last one works.
Here the sides all look like
they're the same length,
but the way we can know
for sure that they are
is these tick marks.
Any time you have these marks,
it's saying that any side that has
the same amount of marks
is the same length.
All four of these sides
have exactly one tick mark
so they are all equal in length.
So shape four matches all three clues.
It is a quadrilateral,
there are no right angles
and it has four sides of equal length.
So shape four is our answer.